in season five of the wire Gus a
newspaper editor says this if you can
describe him as you really is tell the
story in moments get back in shelters
and soup kitchens and just be with
Oakland just spend the day being with
people not interested what do the quota
of counter honest I'm interested in what
feels true this is an ethos that the
wire takes to heart and uses to develop
its themes and ideas as I laid out in
part one of this series on the wire show
creators David Simon and Ed Burns had
intentions for the show that went far
beyond creating entertainment they were
interested in what feels true and they
used moments to examine and develop
their themes in this video I'm going to
show how the wire uses narrative
structure and the juxtaposition and
relationship of scenes and characters to
illustrate ideas to show this I'll have
to spoil aspects of the show if you
haven't seen the show yet and you'd like
a spoiler free overview of why it's
great make sure to watch part one in
this series this video is sponsored by
Nordby pn you can go to nord VPN comm
slash thomas flight to get 75% off a
three-year plan the wire deals with many
issues but its primary focus is
illustrating the city of baltimore by
showing its various institutions and the
individuals that make up those
institutions the show portrays how
economic political and individual
motivations affect how institutions
operate key to the story is how these
motivations keep the institutions in a
cycle of failure and make it difficult
for individuals to reform are you in any
way suggesting that the system's lost
controls but how do you lay out these
ideas on film how do you portray them
without beating your audience over the
head with preachy complicated exposition
one way is to use the technique that gus
describes you show individual moments
and use the relationship between those
moments in different characters lives to
infer certain ideas here's an example
early in season two there are two scenes
that mirror each other visually and in
con
stringer Bell and Avon Barksdale
communicate through the chain-link fence
of a prison there's a Breanna reminded
the myth we've got promises about to
keep I know her daniels and McNulty
communicate through the chain-link
barrier of the evidence room we brought
in a case the conversations in the two
scenes are different in how they relate
to the story but taken together the
scenes illustrate the dysfunction of the
police department who is punishing the
officers that successfully arrested Avon
Barksdale even as they punish Avon
Barksdale
and none of this is in exposition the
wire doesn't tell you this it simply
lets you see it through context and the
visual connection through these kinds of
associations the show creates the city
of Baltimore as a character each
institution and character touches every
other in some way corner kids will take
money that's being given away just like
clay Davis clay Davis is told he
shouldn't flip and needs to carry the
charge against him or you carry this for
all of us carried as far as you can
just like D'Angelo is told the same
thing but you heard him you heard his
whole family D'Angelo is scolded for
being unloyal to his family just like
Carver is scolded for being unloyal to
his police unit you see loyalty they
learn loyalty you show them it's about
the work it'll be about the work Carver
is scolded by lieutenant Daniels for
going outside the chain of command while
Carcetti later thanks Daniels for doing
the same thing well thanks for going
outside the chain of command Carcetti is
trying to do politics differently but
struggles against the cons of clay Davis
so much for laying back on a million we
paid $20,000 for this if you probably
went to Royce and shook him down for a
load of thirty just like stringer Bell
does when trying to reform his drug
empire
Oh about 30,000 coming Batman I'm
talking about the quarter of a mil that
you took now you need to call mr. goose
mr. faucet remember you got a call
because I'll get you money to run
remember that stringer Bell is punished
by his institution for that very attempt
to reform get all what it move just like
bunny Colvin is punished for his attempt
to reform how much you can say is not
real police get on with him Oh Colvin
reaches for a harebrained illegal scheme
to try to force reform when all else
fails legalize drugs which is mirrored
by McNulty's harebrained illegal scheme
to inspire change in season 5 he needs
to be caught McNulty's actions in season
5 lead to him losing what he loves
police work just like Marlo's mistakes
lead to him losing what he loves his
crown was dead even though Marlowe tries
to reform he's drawn back to the streets
just like Avon Barksdale was drawn back
after attempting to reform yeah I know
suit when businessman like you you know
I'm just a gangster I suppose
Avon Barksdale is more interested in
sending a message than ineffectiveness
when the work hard this boy Marlo punkin
me what am I look like just like Police
Commissioner Burrell we need to let them
know who we are
we can't for one minute let them think
that this will stand this is just a
fraction of the ways that characters and
moments are interconnected on the wire I
think you need a lot of context to
seriously examine anything these
connections provide some of the context
necessary to seriously examine the
issues separate individuals are also
used to tell aspects of a broader more
general story a great example of this is
D'Angelo and cutty D'Angelo is on a path
to reform but he's killed before he has
time to complete his arc killing off
D'Angelo is necessary to illustrate the
forces that keep reform from happening
but what if he had made it out of prison
alive what would that have looked like
you put it behind you huh some cane the
wire provides us with Dennis Wise who
Allah straights what D'Angelo's path
might have looked like had he lived
there's an amazing amount of nuance
that's available with this type of
storytelling it's one of the ways the
wire balances precariously on the edge
of cynicism and hope seeing D'Angelo die
is heartbreaking getting to see Cuddy
successfully reform provides a ray of
hope but even then the struggles of
performing are made very clear another
example of this our characters Jimmy
McNulty and kima Gregg's we meet McNulty
in season 1 as a talented but
dysfunctional detective he has a
drinking problem has trouble keeping a
relationship together and is jaded by
his career Chema's arc over the entire
show and the similarities to Jimmy's
helps illustrate how Jimmy may have
ended up the way he was in season 1 by
doing this the wire tells the individual
stories of Jimmy McNulty and kima
Gregg's but it's also telling the
broader story of the jaded dysfunctional
detective it tells the individual story
of D'Angelo Barksdale and cutty wise but
it also tells the broader story of
reformed gangster it tells the
individual story of Michael and Omar
little and the broader story stick-up
man ultimately the stories of the kids
in seasons four and five are the largest
piece of this inter character narrative
by showing each kid's struggles and what
leads them to their final destinations
we see how characters like Omar bubbles
and bunny Colvin may have come to be it
allows us to connect the failure of the
school system to the dysfunction of the
institutions and seasons one through
three but the show isn't so
deterministic as to say that the
individual adhering to the broader story
is inevitable through great effort and a
little luck some individuals can break
through the cycle and behave differently
unfortunately though it often takes
great trauma to inspire an individual to
reform this is the wires call for
individual reform but it's also perhaps
and insinuation that similarly true
reform for institutions may only come
through trauma to the institution
understanding this broader narrative
about institutions helps us understand
why a character like Omar is so
compelling in the world of the show in a
world where so many characters are bound
or hobbled by failing institutions
around them a true rogue a lone rebel is
someone we can root for but all this is
left for the audience to extrapolate for
themselves from individual moments which
keeps the show from feeling like it's
shoving a message down your throat there
are layers to unravel and depths to
examine and interpret but the show
allows you to use your worldview to see
the issues it's laying out even as it
might challenge your own assumptions and
worldview and present its own
[Music]
in the final part of this series I'll be
examining more layers of the onion and
showing why each season of the wire is
important to the overall story so if
you're interested in that subscribe and
hit the bell so you see the next part
when it's released this video is
sponsored by Nordby pn you can go to
nord VPN comm slash thomas flight to get
75% off a three year plan everyone
should have access to a VPN it's an
important part of basic good security as
an Internet user a lot of people don't
realize that when you connect to public
Wi-Fi whether it's with your laptop or
your phone you're often exposed to
hacking or security risks when you use a
VPN like Nord VPN your connection is
encrypted and other people on that
public network can't access your data I
love being able to promote Nord VPN
because it's a company I was using and
paying for long before they ever
sponsored me and I continued using it to
this day they have thousands of
superfast servers in a ton of different
countries they have great apps for iOS
and Android that make it really easy to
connect to the VPN on your phone you can
get 75% off a three-year plan and use
code Thomas flight to get an extra month
for free thank you so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
want you can go to patreon.com/scishow
and creation of this type of content I
really appreciate all my patrons and
I'll talk to you again next time